Let's wrap up our topic for today.
So today,
we've talked about generate and test,
which is a very general purpose
problem solving method.
As Ashok mentioned earlier in
our lesson, we see generate and
test every day in our regular lives and
it's something in which
we engage very naturally.
We talked about strong generators and
strong testers and
how we can build intelligence into one
side or the other in order to make
the problem solving process easier and
more efficient.
We also talked about how generating
tests is more difficult and
unconstrained domains and
how our generator and tester need to be
equipped with special kinds of knowledge
in order to make this problem solvable.
Next, we're going to be looking at two
different problem solving methods that
build on what we've seen
today with generate and test.
Means and analysis and
problem reduction.
Like generate and test, these are both
very general purpose, but they're going
to do things a little bit differently
and make certain problems easier.